Now, let's make some more adjustments to our plot. This time we're
going to use a transformation on the y-axis, so we change the friend count.
We're going to do this so that we can get a better visualization
of the data. Let's see if you can figure this out on your
own. I want you to look at the documentation for coord_trans
and add it as a layer to this plot. The function you're going to
use to transform friend count will be the square root function. See
if you can make the plot and think about any observations you have,
once you've made it. Now here again is an instance where we haven't given
you all the knowledge upfront, but I think you can figure this one out.